this is the theme the danger this is the
things is the d900 lasts long they can
peace be with you
welcome to the Dean show we're very
excited that you're joining us here
tonight on the Dean show you got away
from the late night football game you
got away from all the all the things
that are out there distracting you from
the most important questions in life
what's the purpose of life why am I here
who created me what's the correct way
that I need to be upon to be successful
in this life and in the hereafter and
this is a very very important topic
because many people are heading in
direction and it's the wrong direction
they're taking a man is God saying that
God had a son and all other sorts of
confusion is out there but today we're
going to clear the confusion about one
of the most mightiest messengers that
God ever sent to mankind Jesus peace be
upon him we have dr. Lawrence Brown here
on the Dean show we cleared up the
confusion about Jesus being the only
begotten Son but in today's episode
we're going to clear up the confusion
about him being the son of God when we
come back sit tight
dr. Laura's brown coming up next this is
the theme the danger
this is the me no this is the thesis the
teacher this is the video this is the
thing is athene jus this is the Salam
alaikum peace be with you dr. Lawrence
Brown how are you welcome Salam what
allahi what would a captain thank you
thank you for being on a Deen show again
people can go to the Deen show calm you
have your own private section there they
can read a little bit about you you have
a PhD in religious in religion you have
a DD you're a doctor by profession and
you love talking about these important
issues and when I started the show I
thank everyone who is joining us because
these are serious issues that he took a
time out from the basketball games the
football games maybe they took a time
off from going to the nightclub just for
this night this show because we got
serious things to talk about people are
just getting fed up it's a rat race out
there they want to know the purpose of
life they want to make sure they're
going in the right direction if they're
not and this is a crucial topic because
many people they believe in God is
inherent in their nature but there's
some confusion about Jesus there's some
confusion about Jesus now in one show
that people can see that we did it's at
the Dean show calm we cleared up the
confusion you gave the top five reasons
dr. Brown's top five reasons why Jesus
peace be upon him who we loved dearly he
is not the begotten Son of God now you
have some a few more that you're going
to share for us how many exactly well on
this episode we're going to be talking
about eight top reasons eight top
reasons why Jesus Christ was not the son
of God we got to get right into it let's
start with number eight wasting no time
I'll take it away
we were talking about the tenets of
Christian faith of Jesus Christ being
considered the only begotten Son of God
we dispelled the only we dispelled the
begotten now we're just going to talk
about the concept of Jesus Christ being
considered the Son of God okay so number
eight the reason why Jesus Christ was
not the Son of God many Christians say
Jesus Christ was the son of God because
Jesus called God Father Jesus called god
father
so Jesus must be the son of God however
what do you call that I mean I bet that
most people out there when they pray to
God they say oh yeah our Father why did
I say our Father because Jesus Christ
instructed his followers he said when
you pray pray in this way our Father
didn't say my father he said our Father
our Father that's a instructed everybody
to pray in this way our Father who art
in heaven hallowed be thy name etc etc
etc the Lord's Prayer so the point is
that this is not this is not an argument
hold that holds water you cannot use
this argument to say Jesus Christ was
the son of God because he called God
Father because Jesus Christ told all of
his followers to call God our Father
that's number eight that's number eight
Lilliana number now I'm moving on let's
go to number seven number seven some
people say just Jesus Christ might be
the son of God because other people
identified Jesus Christ as the Son of
God first of all this is not quite true
the passage or the or the words pious
theö are translated to son of God but
the primary meaning the primary
translation of pious Theo is servant
servant of God okay now all right don't
trust me on this let's say that you even
prefer to translate pious Theo as son of
God look at it from a different angle we
find pious Theo eight times in the New
Testament five times reference Jesus
once in
book of Matthew 12:15 and four times in
acts okay but there are three times that
we find pious Theo that did not relate
to Jesus at all two of them relate to
David and once in Luke and once in acts
one relates to Israel in Luke 154 so you
can look all these up but the bottom
line is that five times Jesus Christ is
identified as pious Theo twice David is
identified as pious do once Israel is
identified as pious Theo despised Theo
means son of God that means you have to
include not only Jesus but you have to
count David and Israel into the formula
as well all right and since nobody does
that you have to throw the entire
concept out okay moving on so now we
cover we got eight eight of the top
eight why he's not the son of God and
we're moving on we went from eight seven
let's hit six because it relates to just
what I was talking about take it away
with number six okay
pious Theo means servant of God but it's
been translated to son of God the other
word that you find in the New Testament
most commonly that is translated to son
is spelled hu i/os Julio's this is
translated metaphorically when you see
son of in the Bible almost always it's
Julio's but almost always it is
translated metaphorically all right the
meaning is metaphorical I'll give you an
example Matthew 17 25 the believers are
identified sons of the king sons of the
king Luke 19 9 God's elect are
identified as sons of Abraham Matthew 7
9 the believers are identified as God's
sons as what God's sons and those are
the believers okay so if the believers
are God's sons that means all believers
are God's sons okay now you can
understand that literally or
figuratively metaphorically I'll give
you a hint
students in Matthew 12 27 students are
identified as sons of the Pharisees in
John 19 26 the favorite disciple is
identify
why does Mary's son even though he
wasn't Mary's son okay you go on to
matthew 8:12 you find sons of the
kingdom you go to Luke 10 six we've got
sons of peace Luke 16 eight sons of
light sons of this world sons of thunder
does any of this sound real when does
any of the sound literal sons of this
world sons of light sons of thunder a
lot of sons of sons of kingdoms sons of
God sons of Abraham sons of the
believers sons of no this is all
metaphorical and if we look at the
scholars leading to item number five if
we look at the scholars the scholars
tell us this has to be a metaphor it
can't be anything but a metaphor right
this is reason number five so we're
moving on a fire reason number five why
Jesus Christ is not the Son of God is
because scholars tell us it's not
possible for this to be literal it can
only be metaphor why because if it was
intended literally in in the time of
Jesus Christ it would have been
considered blasphemy and anybody who had
said it according to the laws of the Old
Testament would have been considered as
disbeliever and would have been executed
so you have to either accept it as a
metaphor or if not as a metaphor it
would have been blasphemous and those
those who proposed it would have would
have been punished for blasphemy so
we're going to stop at five we went from
eight to five when we come back we're
going to do four sounds good to me
we'll be right back with number four the
top eight dr. Lawrence Brown here and
the Dean show this is I don't say to
people I used to be a Christian I still
carry the values and principles of
loving Jesus Christ and perhaps maybe
more than even call themselves
Christians so I think I got the best out
of Christianity by becoming Muslim
so many other things that you can enjoy
without drinking a sip of alcohol this
is the same thing it's not an obstacle
it's not something to cause people to
get completely desperate and start
stopping living their lives no it should
be a motivation it's only one life that
you're going to be living so you better
do it for a lot of China Matata
I am Not Afraid to stand alone I am Not
Afraid to stand alone if allies by my
side I am not afraid to stand alone I am
not afraid to stand alone
if allies by my side I am not afraid to
stand alone I am Not Afraid to stand
alone if Allah I am Not Afraid of
back here on the Dean show with dr.
Lawrence Brown and we're giving the
people that top eight reasons in this
show why Jesus is not the Son of God
never claimed to be the Son of God could
not be the Son of God and you're on a
roll
you went from eight now we're on four
mm-hmm please continue on okay number
four number four reason why Jesus Christ
was not the son of God or why we should
believe that Jesus Christ was not the
Son of God is that Jesus Christ did not
call himself the Son of God okay we have
to believe that Jesus Christ was what he
said he was he never called him so he
never called never the Son of God okay
okay what do we have to back up that
position okay
Hastings Bible Dictionary says whether
Jesus used it the term sir the son of
God whether Jesus used it of himself is
doubtful Harper's Bible Dictionary says
it even more clearly quote Jesus never
claims for himself the title son of God
now these are these are from respected
Bible dictionaries and they are telling
us that Jesus Christ never called
himself the Son of God now I know what a
lot of people out there thinking they're
thinking I've read my Bible I find son
of God you have to understand that what
the scholars are talking about are not
what you find in your translation what
the scholars are talking about is what
they find in the manuscripts from which
the Bible is translated okay there's a
very important point a person can
translate a document to read whatever
they want it to read you have to go to
the source documents to really
understand what it says precisely okay
but even in your Bibles even in your
Bibles you will find that Jesus never
called himself the Son of God in a
literal begotten not made sense so
that's number four that's number four
we're going to number three we got three
left there is there's a statement among
Christian missionaries it's called the
trilemma
all right they come up to us and they
say look Jesus was either a liar he was
a lunatic or he was the son of God
he said he was mm-hmm okay well look as
Muslims we agree Jesus Christ was not a
liar he was not a lunatic he was exactly
what he said he was but where did he say
that he was the son of God he didn't but
What did he say he was reason number
three Jesus called himself what the Son
of Man 88 times go and count them 88
times Jesus identified himself as the
Son of Man not as the Son of God as the
Son of Man the new Catholic Encyclopedia
states quote this title is of special
interest because it was the one employed
by Jesus by preference to designate
himself and his mission now that's the
new Catholic Encyclopedia telling us
that Jesus Christ employed the title son
of man by preference to dexon to
designate himself and his mission that's
number three reasons why we should
understand that Jesus Christ was not the
Son of God he's a very simple and not
complicated understand I want to get
through these that's yes and I have a
few important questions very important
question I want to ask you so continue
on we're going to number two now number
two reasons why Jesus Christ why we
should realize he's not the Son of God
Jesus is identified in the New Testament
14 times 14 times as the son of David
who was Jesus's father was it David
no no we find in the Book of Luke a list
of genealogy from David forty-one
generations until it works its way down
to Jesus Christ and even then we have to
remember that Jesus Christ didn't have a
father okay
he was born by he was born to the Virgin
Mary as a divine miracle a sign from God
of the of the fact that he was a prophet
but in any case we have David forty-one
generations and the book of Luke before
we get to Jesus if you look in Matthew
it's 26 generations
let's not get hung up over the fact that
Luke and Matthew can't agree that's a
different point to be made about the
Bible let's just acknowledge that Jesus
Christ is called the son of David
fourteen times in the Bible and he most
definitely was not the son of David so
what do we have here if if the Bible is
saying literally that he was the son of
David the Bible is wrong and you have to
rectify and error in the Bible with your
belief that the Bible is the Word of God
because obviously God doesn't make a
mistake
or you have to recognize as we have
already discussed that in fact the
language is figurative it is
metaphorical it is not meant to be taken
literally now that's a fast number
that's number two now people are going
to have to hold up for number one
because I have to ask you a very serious
question I'm dr. Brown now someone might
say you know what okay this sounds all
good you're making sense but you know
from from a child you know I've been
brought up to believe that you know
there's a big fat man Santa Claus coming
down the chimney I've been I've been
programmed to believe you know the Tooth
Fairy is going to come and you know take
my tooth under the pillow etc etc we get
programmed with a lot of things you know
some people grow out of that all right
but now this this is something that's
even more serious and they say you know
what what's the big deal I'll just if I
make a mistake if this is wrong on that
day of judgment I look God in the eye
and I'll say you know what God I'm sorry
and we'll take it from there what you
got to say about that well you know I
think that we've you know we've touched
on this before I mean the bottom line is
that this life is our test and with the
end of this life that's the end of the
test and there are no apologies later in
the same way that you can't go to your
teacher at the end of your final exam
and ask him to open the book and let you
change it you know once the exam is done
once that exam book is closed your deeds
are done in this life when you die that
is that that is the closure upon
your deeds and that at that moment you
lose the ability to go back and fix
anything you can it's finished this is
your shot right now our shizzit this is
what life is all about
look God could have taken all of us and
put us in paradise
directly if he wanted to or he could
have taken us and put us in Hellfire but
instead he put us in this life with free
will to choose our own direction and
based upon our choices based upon the
path that we choose for ourselves
whether to be pious and righteous or not
that is going to sort out the people who
go to paradise the people who go to hell
and the degrees of their punishment and
the degrees of their reward okay but but
but our deeds our deeds and when our
lives end now is this an insult to God
to say that God had a son it's just
something that is absolutely it's an
insult absolutely why because because
first of all how can God have a son when
he doesn't have a consort all right set
secondly we know from the first
commandment right not to place partners
beside God and we know that the most
important important important
commandment is that know your God is one
God all right three times in the Bible
three times in the New Testament Jesus
Christ II is asked about the most
important commandment and this is what
he states he says Nowell Israel your God
is one God he'd look if there were such
a thing as a Trinity if Jesus Christ
were the Son of God if there were
mysteries of faith that would have been
the place to have ascetic I mean that
would have been the place to have said
no o Israel the Lord your God the Lord
is one but it's not quite that simple
there are other elements to it let me
explain he didn't say that
all right he said the Lord your God the
Lord is one period and it's recorded
three times in the Bible
and there is no you know there are no
passages which contradict that or shed
another light on that and what is
revelation
what is revelation reveal Asian the
point of Revelation is to reveal this
this is God conveying through a human
agent his word to mankind to reveal to
us the reality of him and the reality of
his laws okay so this this is where he's
going to make it clear to us why would
there be such a thing as a Trinity and
he doesn't make that clear to us why
would there be such a thing as the Son
of God and he doesn't he doesn't clarify
that I'm giving you all the reasons why
we should realize that Jesus Christ was
not the Son and we're going to give them
the number one reason and they're going
to have to hold on to after the break
we'll be right back with the number one
reason why Jesus peace be upon him was
not the Son of God with dr. Lewis Brown
be right back from home and if we're
going to worship something I figured I
might as well worship the Creator
instead of any of the creations now in
upon investigating the village's I
remember finding out the meaning of what
Islam is what Muslim is those who
surrender their self to God is a Muslim
those who surrender submit to God God's
will that is it Islam was pure it was
just you just pray to God you create
when outside everything looks good you
see the hundred thousand dollar cars you
see a lot of diamonds you see a lot of
females and they think that this is you
know this is a life this is this is like
no paradise right here are just not any
one job to go into someone's heart and
change their heart your job is to topi
what the truth is
and the alley of it is while we're
sitting here while I'm sitting here
constantly paying for the disease the
kill was free back here on the Dean show
and you been patiently awaiting for the
number one reason why Jesus peace be
upon him who we love very dearly he was
one of the mightiest messages of God we
believe but he was not the Son of God
never claimed to be and you're going to
now give us God willing the number one
reason from your top eight please go
ahead dr. Brown all right the number one
reason is well how many sons of God are
you going to believe it Christian
doctrine tells us that Jesus Christ was
the only begotten Son of God
there was only one son of God and that
was Jesus Christ and yet Jeremiah 31
nine states quote for I meaning God this
is God speaking for I am a father to
Israel and Ephraim is my firstborn well
now wait a minute
Jesus Christ is the only begotten Son of
God how can God be the father to Israel
and Ephraim is his firstborn how is that
possible but that's what it says
Jeremiah 31 verse 9 Romans 8 verse 14
quote for as many as are led by the
Spirit of God they are what they are the
sons of God Exodus 4 22 Israel is my son
even my firstborn know what part of that
is mysterious Israel is my son
even my firstborn so you have to you
have to start making a list really of
who is who is the Son of God and who is
not and that list is not short Luke 3:38
Adam which was the son of God okay
- Samuel 713 identifies Solomon as the
Son of God Genesis 6:2 6 for Doodle
Romani Deuteronomy 14 1 you can go to
job 1 6 2 1 38 7 all of these passages
identify individuals or groups as sons
of God or children of God
everybody knows the passage Matthew 5:9
blessed are the peacemakers blessed are
the peacemakers for they shall be called
the sons of God
okay so let's just tabulate a whole list
here we've got Israel we've got Solomon
we've got Adam we've got countless
individuals who are identified by group
not by individual but by groups as
children or sons of God so where does
the list end on one hand you have the
Bible saying all of these people are
sons of God on the other hand you have
the church saying Jesus Christ was the
only begotten Son of God again there's a
big problem
you cannot rectify these two they are
mutually exclusive you can't say one
person is the only begotten Son of God
and then all these other people are sons
were children of God as well okay so
something is wrong
the church is wrong the Bible is wrong
something is wrong and I think most
people know it so this is the number one
reason why we should realize Jesus
Christ is not the Son of God it's
because so many people were spoken of as
sons of God literally and it begotten
not made sense no once again we have to
realize this is metaphorical it is not
meant to be taken literally it is an
expression of closeness to God is it is
an Express
of piety but it is not an expression of
reality it is not a literal expression
of sonship as we understand sonship in a
literal sense now we're almost out of
time in the last minute that we have
please tell us because some people might
think man these guys are the Antichrist
what's going on here so are we -
Antichrist and tell us just in the one
minute that we have briefly you know
where people can also go after you
explain that we're not the Antichrist
how people can get in contact with you
and learn more about this topic look
you're not the Antichrist when you speak
up for what Christ Himself taught we are
supporting what Jesus Christ actually
taught we believe in him as a man and as
a prophet as he taught us to believe in
him okay you-you-you do not denigrate
the Prophet by tearing down the the lies
that have been constructed in his name
because should he return he would be the
first one to attack those as well he
would be the first one to say I never
said that where can you find this
information everything that you have
heard tonight you can find on my
websites and a great deal more level
truth the calm and eight scroll calm
level truth just as it sounds the two
words level truth calm eighth scroll is
dedicated to a book called the eighth
scroll just look it up two words eighths
worldcom i'm going to have to have you
back again
inshallah I want to thank you again they
got Almighty Allah rewards you for being
with us thank you thank you and that was
dr. Lawrence Brown here on the Dean show
and we have given you he gave you eight
of the top eight reasons why Jesus peace
be upon him who we loved dearly was not
could not have been never claimed to be
the Son of God God doesn't have sons or
daughters he was not a man or woman he
created man and woman he's the one God
who Jesus prayed to throughout time God
has sent messengers and that message
that they deliver was always the same
worship the Creator and not his creation
and we hope that you got to benefit and
we look forward to having you here again
with us next time inshallah God willing
then peace be unto you